we're gonna do a little relationship
advice next do I feel like we're helping
people it's relationship advice if
there's one thing I can say we're
helping the world really dude yep oh hey
you live you right yeah man oh dude me
and my girl got married cuz you're
[ __ ] ganking buzz-buzz Mike yeah there
you go
there you go we just named our kid gang
buzz maybe who have helped in the world
eh
we're definitely helping the people that
make birth certificates though laughs a
little what do you got we got Chris from
Montreal Quebec this is great mom
Bienvenue so voice greetings from
Montreal sorry for the lighting needs
some relationship advice you know so I
took this summer volunteering program at
a residence and asked out my supervisor
on the third week timer now I'm 18 and
she's 21
mmm she said no because it would be
unethical and I know she's pretty
serious about rules I'm still kind of
interested so I was wondering what you
guys think about it do I wait until the
end of the summer and ask her out again
but then I'd be waiting for a month for
a girl I barely know or do I give up and
move on and wait for her to make the
next move since I've already made mine
appreciate it
love you boys no homo buzz buzz game
game buzz buzz damn he seems super
stressed about it here's the thing like
Ryan Reynolds which is hilarious that
were running Deadpool references today
oh why you think Ryan Reynolds he like
real Reynolds oh yeah interesting
yeah um you gonna take offense that
listen dude if you don't want to wait a
month I mean it's not that long brother
no anyway 18 a month seems like years
but if you can't wait a month she ain't
worth it and also you guys and
technically it's against the rules
well yeah man that's your boss can't
[ __ ] your boss on summer break dude yeah
so wait a month see what's up yeah man
she's worth it you know I'm saying yeah
first of all you're waiting a month we
like wait a month she already said no so
you're just waiting like yes that much
of a debate she kind of said no
youth workers so I think maybe I think
yeah you could after our way to the end
I wouldn't make her feel uncomfortable
be standing around what flowers are like
a little candy thing or something or one
of those [ __ ] things you get where
you get the fruit cutting the flowers
and they send it with the cones in there
trusting their cousin pineappley the
[ __ ] kids off to the sky also keep
your peepers off for a two-man don't
make her feel uncomfortable yeah bro you
know I would wear glasses in class if
you have to or sunglasses or dark
glasses mm-hm even do a disguise or
something you know and say you just want
to make her feel as comfortable as
possible so if she doesn't think it's
you staring at her then that might be
good so if you do like a little light
disguise or like a different type of
bigger shirt it's a good idea wonder
where I had every now and then yeah do
like a big hat like a kind of a outdoor
kind of hat or like a Nordic if she see
if she really cares about you pretend
you're sick and miss multiple weeks see
if she calls you she's not gonna call
dude she's she's not into it well we've
gotta waste our time cuz she kinda was
like I'm not into he's like should I
wait a month
I wouldn't I'd move on yeah just don't
move on outside of her door dude you
know just keep it chill I would I would
wait till classes over and then maybe
send a little message or something and
just but just be appropriate about it
and just say hey look uh you know III
think we should I'm still interested if
you are and then just see what a
response is dude this what I'd do I'd
made I'd make a mix tape on her ass yeah
who's who's doing that these days drop
her a nice little mixtape with a little
genuine on there yeah a little Jake
sadly but make a mixtape with just that
song on it ten times in a row
so she really gets the message yeah dude
that's a great idea or do a heart of or
draw art of her yeah if you can draw
otherwise it's gonna scare it's gonna
scare either way and but hey was brave e
to shoot your shot man you know she's
the teacher and he took a shot at the
teacher a lot of young guys are afraid
to do that a lot of half your class is
probably sitting around jerking off at
night to her and at least you tried to
man up you know yeah take some balls to
do that but maybe move on
back up my broccolini get your life
together